your your thing with Ragnarok right uh I
I was curious too because I've read some
comments out there you know they they
think that we just agree on everything
all the time yeah I think this is the
first time we've disagree yeah yeah on a
movie like I love Ragnarok
um but and I didn't like love and
thunder um
but when you look at it at the bigger
picture too though like the first two
thoughts in five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of The Genius brain podcast we
have Ed parkvp in here what's up today's
gonna be an interesting one because
can do the movie reviews again but not
just movie reviews let's start off with
this though because
you know love and thunder didn't get as
much love
as I thought it was going to get right
only because of stuff that they're
complaining about is the same [ __ ] I
complained about with Ragnarok and every
everybody gave me [ __ ] they're like it's
an amazing move what are you talking
about you don't know who taika Wati the
funniest [ __ ] thing is every
complaint that I had about Ragnarok it's
exactly why people didn't like love and
thunder and now that I was like okay I
know what love and Thunder's gonna be
about yeah I'm going to enjoy the jokes
and I was like I enjoyed the movie and
they're like dude it was a terrible
movie I'm like [ __ ] you guys [ __ ] all of
you
this is why I stick to my [ __ ] guns
and by the way by no stretch of the
imagination did I say that it was an
amazing movie yeah I said it was [ __ ]
funny and the jokes were placed way
better than Ragnarok yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's it yeah I uh I I just saw it too
finally
and I gotta tell you I walked out kind
of pissed
and then I had to sleep on it I had to
recognize I laughed a lot I did laugh a
lot and I I think I discounted that
because of the way I felt leaving
um but like it's it's I don't think
there's a problem with it where we're
gonna break it down like we did chongqi
and Doctor Strange yeah you know but uh
because it wasn't trying to be something
that it wasn't yeah so there's nothing
to break down if you look at it for what
it is I feel like it's the mcu's Dude
Where's My Car yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah the mcu's Harold and Kumar yeah
that's straight irreverent comedy right
like
um the problem for me we'll we'll get
into that we'll get into it but um for
like your your thing with Ragnarok right
uh I I was curious too because I I've
read some comments out there you know
they they think that we just agree on
everything all the time yeah I think
this is the first time we've disagreed
yeah yeah on a movie like I love
Ragnarok
um but and I didn't like love and
Thunder
um but when you look at it at the bigger
picture too though like the first two
Thor's right the first one is specially
yeah like how do you bring a character
like this into the MCU
and of course God right right and what
they did was pretty genius I think they
turned it into a Shakespearean film they
got a Shakespearean trained actor and
director Kenneth Brana who also makes
great films to this day and he's an
awesome
um you know actors well one of the best
actors I love seeing him and stuff uh he
did Death on a Nile I think murder on
the Orion Express he's directed those
um but he is a Shakespearean classically
trained actor that's why Anthony Hopkins
is in it and um the the acting you see
in it looks like a Shakespearean play
because how do you get these King James
people like they the way they talk is
like super old school King James yeah
and then
um
then they had to let that go because
apparently like Chris Hemsworth was like
this character [ __ ] boring yeah like
it's limited to something and so once
they brought Taiko YTD for Ragnarok it
really opened it up to more of like a
comedic kind of
um I don't I don't know if I want to say
improv but um it made Thor way more
contemporary yeah and down to earth
right
um but once we got into love and Thunder
but like okay tell me tell me what you
think like like from what what you've
seen it's a for me it's a good comedy
movie that's what it is it's a comedy
it's a comedy movie this [ __ ] is not
going to progress anything you're not
going to get a lot of debt the only
redeemable thing in terms of
a movie that I really enjoyed was
Christian Bale Christian Bale killed it
Christian Bale is the Saving Grace of
the film because he took that role on so
seriously yeah and you want to talk
about a [ __ ] good villain yeah and
his Redemption Arc is what I also
enjoyed so in terms of like him not just
being this bad guy there's a reason for
why he is this which I feel a lot of
people [ __ ] up on who maybe we can talk
about that later because that first
opening scene spoke to me so hard
because you know you know me and my
journey with Christianity
um when it was he was going through that
whole thing like okay so he and his
daughter uh her name is Love which hence
we find out later that love is is her
and the title of the film
um
she dies because they're like their
planet is dying and then they're in a
Barren desert they're they're trying to
survive and she dies but Christian
Bell's character Gore the god butcher he
um still he survives and he I guess he
hears the calling of The Necromancer
sword I believe that's what it's called
I forget yeah yeah yeah
um which is basically the god killer the
god killing yeah and then he meets his
God and His God doesn't give a [ __ ]
about him and it's a very box him it's a
huge Ode to Adam and Eve it's like the
Garden of Eden he's literally living in
this land of just Paradise Paradise it's
Lush there's flowers trees water fruit
everything is so [ __ ] abundant and
Gore comes up he's [ __ ] up dehydrated
sunburned
still worships his God despite losing
everything his God mocks him mocks him I
did this for you and he goes doesn't
[ __ ] matter you're gonna die anyways
yeah everyone was dead yeah he doesn't
give a [ __ ]
and
um The Necromancer or that sword
presents itself and he kills that God
and then he vows to
kill all the gods Across The Universe
And that's pretty much title
and then uh
we get to where Thor is
um we have Korg the rock guy who's
voiced by Taiko with TD
um he's kind of giving the narrative
what happened before where he's like fat
and whatever and then he worked out
right and then now he's joined the
Guardians
um I gotta say visually
visually one of the best looking MCU
films colorful just striking imagery
um and
like uh so what you see though is like
he's kind of there like I don't know if
you want to say secret weapon like he's
their last resort because he is so
[ __ ] powerful that he comes in when
he has to
but um
the the
the weird thing about that opening scene
is that he after all that's happened
after end game
he still has this sense of longing I
guess like like
there's still more to to be done the
only way I could kind of relate to that
is the fact that you know after I've
lost like a hundred pounds I was like my
life isn't finished yes I still have to
live the rest of my life yeah there's
still so much to do in it and I think
um his character is still seeking out
that there is things out to do and then
he gets some distressed call from Sif
who hasn't been around since the second
Thor movie yeah and that that seemed
like I came here too I thought she would
have done something but then so he ends
up going to new Asgard and then Tessa
Thompson's character Valkyrie is now the
new king of new Asgard
and uh she's doing like Old Spice
commercials she's doing like bureaucracy
stuff by the way have you seen the
current Old Spice commercials
so uh you know in Ragnarok when Thor
goes back to Asgard there's that Cameo
with Matt Damon yeah and they're doing
that theater play that's in like uh
that's kind of like a fourth wall thing
towards the first and second movies how
they were Shakespearean plays so they
were just kind of reenacting yeah yeah
yeah right
um yeah that's that's Chris Hemsworth's
brother
the yeah not Liam but then they have
another brother who's like shorter oh
the one that's playing uh that's [ __ ]
that's his brothers dude yeah I have no
idea yeah so both of them make a cameo
appearance again and Sam Neil the main
character from Jurassic Park yeah he's
the one that's playing Odin
hilarious and then uh Melissa McCarthy
spoiler alert guy sorry yeah I'm pretty
sure everybody saw it by now yeah So
like
um I kind of when it happened in
Ragnarok like I understood that joke for
the fact that the past two movies were
like Shakespearean films
um this time around it kind of felt like
a diminishing return like they kind of
pulled out the same joke again
I mean it was still what it's worth it
was still funny yeah
um still did its purpose was to like
because we talked about how Dr Strange
just was just like hey Wanda's bad guy
who cares if you didn't catch up with it
but at least they did their due
diligence yeah and catching up with with
where they're at right
um to be honest for me at this point
I really felt like this is one of the
worst edited films I've ever seen not
even just in the MCU for me it was the
edit because I'm an editor by trade
um I couldn't believe how I couldn't
breathe or the film wasn't breathe
allowing you to breathe oh for sure it
was so but then we're going back like
this is a comedy
for me it felt like a really long
YouTube's kit yeah but that's the thing
too that's how I felt about Ragnarok
though right like Ragnarok felt like
that it was just joke joke joke joke
because I wasn't expecting this [ __ ]
the other guy's movie right you know but
this one I expected it to be like the
other guys yes yes and so my all my
expectations that I had from Ragnarok
that I got disappointed from I erased it
and I went with this new mind state
right because it's 100 yeah there's
nothing there's no breathing room for
[ __ ] anything it's literally just
throughout the whole [ __ ] which was a
huge complaint that other people had
which is why I was wondering why people
like Ragnarok so much right right right
you know so it was that was the odd part
for me because like I'm on the other
side now but they're like how come you
don't like ragnaroks because I wasn't
expecting it to be like this dude one of
the funniest things of the film where I
I was actually in tears laughing was
[ __ ] Zeus
uh Russell Crow Russell Crowe doing that
stupid Greek accent had me crying
laughing yeah because of how ridic you
know who would remind me of Jack Black
Jack Black
it was he was [ __ ]
what's his name [ __ ] Um nacho libre
nice
to say it it's naturally yeah I wasn't
dying I was like that's [ __ ] Nacho
Libre dude this other Greek
obscure Greek accent this guy who was
just so aloof and just so stupid just
hilarious philosophy yeah
that's what it was dude she wore my
Libre yeah dog I could not stop laughing
because of how ridiculous Russell Crowe
was dude yeah I mean like I said every
time um there were so many set changes
but my God was it beautiful yeah right
my only complaint like I said was that I
wish I had time to breathe like
um it was like the movie's like an hour
45 I felt like it could have been two
hours 215 yeah
um and that maybe would have helped me
digest it but that was just literally
the only complaint otherwise the other
thing too wasn't like really big on
character development because as far as
Thor goes like so much of his story has
been told because he lost so much yeah
um but when as the movie progresses what
you see is it's actually Jane Foster is
part of like a co-star yeah um a big
part of it is her story
um and it was actually
I don't know how to how to say it but
then uh spoiler she has cancer stage
four yeah right um and Natalie Portman
and her own right is a very great
actress and she played it through great
but I
okay so here's the thing have you heard
people say the book is better than the
movie yeah yeah yeah yeah I am against
that idea I always think of movie no
matter what is is still going to be
better than a book for me because of how
I digest things yeah yeah and I'm just
talking about mediums but then obviously
their story is is a big part of it that
can be expounded on so much in a book
um because I've seen the panels and the
comic books of how Jane Foster becomes
Mighty Thor
um I was hoping to see that transition
they actually didn't show it yeah that
was kind of a they kind of blue balled
my ass on that one I was like
how yeah they kind of did the oh the
hammer started shaking and then the next
thing you know boom she's yeah um
what I just heard recently apparently
there's a four hour and 30 minute
version of this movie get the I want to
see that I want to see that film yeah
yeah so I'm so ready for that like
apparently there's like um Jeff Goldblum
makes a comeback uh Peter Dinklage
apparently his character from endgame oh
yeah he also was supposed to be in the
film or something but they cut out damn
your three hours of this film
um so who knows maybe Disney plus
there'll be a white TD cut yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I mean there's just so
many things too like
that that point where they just kind of
placed her in as she just suddenly got
these Powers was kind of just cut cut
yep and it was just right there and then
we just kind of had to dispend belief
and just kind of yeah it just kind of
continues there's a lot of that in that
movie but once again I expected all the
[ __ ] yeah I knew it was going to be like
that you know well not like that per se
but then I just wanted the jokes to be
better like here's a great example of a
joke that I really thought they did well
it was something small that made me die
laughing it was just
uh Thor finally goes to see what's
happening with all these gods that are
being killed and he finds one of um I
don't know what his citizens are called
but whatever he got omnipotence
play something like that yeah yeah yeah
and then she's out there she goes what's
what's the at not Asgard but where's the
place that they go after they die
uh they go and see eternity yeah so they
go into eternity right and she's like
she's like just leave me here to die so
I could go and do eternity he goes dude
you gotta die in battle she's like [ __ ]
these really small jokes you know which
is kind of [ __ ] hilarious because
there's like there is like this legend
that you hear from a lot of different
cultures like dying in battle will give
you honor and reward right she couldn't
even do that my lovely genius farts this
podcast is brought to you by better help
how well would you take care of your car
if you had to keep the same one your
entire life that's how our brains work
so why don't we treat them the same way
how we care for our minds affects how we
experience life so it's important to
invest time and caring to keeping them
healthy my friends I've used better help
for years now and you guys already know
when it comes to my mental health it is
a priority am I better help online
therapist helps me through my darkest
times and I'm not just saying that my
friends I know just because you hear it
on a podcast ad you feel like I'm just
reading off a piece of paper and I am
not I have used better help for a very
long time and if you haven't tried
online therapy you should because there
are so many benefits to it number one
better help with online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
only therapy sessions so you don't have
to see anyone on camera if you don't
want to it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy and you could be
matched with a therapist in under 48
Hours our listeners get 10 off their
first month at betterhealth.com genius
that's
betterhelp.com genius
but I feel like the previous film would
have just had to go back and forth on
this joke right oh yeah I'm supposed to
die so yeah if you do that then this
will happen oh yeah if I yeah and then
my brother turn into a snake and then
stab me yeah that that kind of like ran
on a bit they didn't do any of that [ __ ]
it was the joke was there they moved on
and they let us continue to another joke
another joke that [ __ ] crapped me it
was something really small it's when the
the [ __ ] rock character was gay got
married
the wrong
bro that [ __ ] [ __ ] got me super hard
dude a lot of people in theater didn't
get that joke yeah they just thought it
was funny that he was gay I was like no
the gay part's not the joke it's the
fact that it's The Rock
Dwayne that [ __ ] [ __ ] cracked me up
man I think it's probably because of the
fast pace of the editing the cut a lot
of it could have been lost in that as
well I mean like because I I enjoyed
like very much uh movies uh do you see
JoJo rabbit no oh you got to see JoJo
rabbit okay yeah it's excellent maybe we
can do a review of that too yeah but
yeah um you know we
I I talked about earlier about how in a
Shakespearean or the the drama play you
see the masks right sadness and and
laughter right someone's crying and
someone's laughing but the idea is that
they're both feeling the same thing
which is pain drama right but it's it's
how it's expressed and such taikaway TD
does a great job at talking about a sad
subject but making it a [ __ ] comedy
so one of his earlier films too the the
hunt for the Wilder people have you seen
that one uh that's what the the kid that
was the fat New Zealand kid in Deadpool
2. that [ __ ] movie was fun yeah yeah
so I mean it's a very sad subject yeah
um he's a foster child and then his
foster [ __ ] dies and in his
foster father doesn't really give a [ __ ]
but then the journey is about their
relationship out in the wilderness right
Jojo rabbit to oh my God such a heavy
subject matter super sad yet one of the
funniest films you'll ever see okay
right and even in Ragnarok too he
touched on some important parts like
First Act ending with their father dying
in a very touching moment and then it
goes into like a huge Adventure as well
but at the end of it too what happens
their [ __ ] home gets destroyed Asgard
gets destroyed you know but then it's
all about the process it's all about the
growth and you know it's it's it's it's
about the journey that they take in
there and take up with TT does that very
well
um there's a lot of high stakes yes yeah
yeah and in this one too there is a lot
of hurt and pain with Jane Foster's
cancer
um
but
other than that I got kind of lost in
what Thor was supposed to do like where
Thor's character growth was yeah you
know
um because it might be because Loki's
not around either
oh yeah that was like his biggest thing
it's like this this whole issue with his
family which I think a lot of people can
relate to it's like that one kid who was
forgotten yeah and you know just wants
to be loved yeah and then the other
brother who loves him truly but he can't
even see it because he's blinded by
jealousy you know a lot of like it
honestly reminds me a lot of like
biblical references oh yeah for sure uh
Cain and Abel yeah right so like Loki's
character was always there for us to
understand why Thor Isn't So Perfect why
Thor isn't so great despite being the
strongest mightiest Avenger right
um and without Loki to be there to
humanize him I think that was Jane
Foster's job in this film to bring Thor
down to earth which they did a pretty
decent job at like uh when they go
through and Montage through their actual
relationship that they had that they
didn't see
um they the like I said this movie does
cover everything it does cover a lot of
bases which is so crazy to think that
they cut it so many hours Short yeah
yeah yeah yeah and I would love to see
that four hour cut but yeah
um that at the end of the day there's
not a lot to talk about with it because
it just is what it is yeah the the one's
not bad yeah and I think that
um I don't know I think I read this too
is
maybe people who are being a little
analytical of the movie and once again I
didn't really see it through that eye
because if I did I probably wouldn't
have liked it as much was the idea of
you know him and Jane Foster's
relationship is supposed to be this
amazing thing and it kind of seemed
towards the end he just kind of accepted
her death you know what I mean it's like
I understand she's dying yeah good job
younger I thought you were supposed to
[ __ ] save her yeah I guess that's not
the case yeah you know so that was kind
of this this is where for me like the
forgiving thing about this film though
that I think that I like better than
Ragnarok is literally Christian Bale
yeah it has to be Christian but just
because like
I always love it the most when you can
really humanize the villain where the
villain isn't just a villain just
because they're evil right there's a
good good [ __ ] reason for it right
and that's the same thing that I feel
like Scarlet Witch had too but they just
didn't do it well in the movie because
we how are we supposed to know this [ __ ]
unless we see it yeah unless we [ __ ]
watch One Division a side note Mary will
finally watched One Division and she
loved it I loved it I just told you just
wait it's because you know what the
issue is with her is that
she's watched so much Korean drama where
they just give you everything in the
first episode she goes oh why is taking
so long
she's watching
one of the things that she does that
drives me [ __ ] nuts I love you my
sweet sweet lady she'll watch some [ __ ]
right and the movie just started and she
goes why is that person doing that if
you watch the movie they'll tell you
they will
tell you that is what the story is for
throughout the whole thing why are they
doing that what's the purpose of that
yeah you know what I don't [ __ ] know
either yeah not yet they'll show us soon
but then that was the other parts why we
have problems with films when we do
question that and then it doesn't pay
off yeah there's no payoff for it
there's no payoff for it that's when you
can be like why do they do that yeah you
know yeah also too I wanted to know why
maybe they did in the film and once
again I only watched this one time was
why did
the hammer choose her
right yeah right
um
Thor asked the hammer to watch over her
but then why would they give her the
power though like I don't understand
that yeah I missed that too yeah um I I
think it's on The Cutting Room floor man
there's two more hours of this stuff
apparently that nobody saw yeah you know
and then you know I don't I'm seeing a
pattern here because we haven't enjoyed
a lot of phase four right phase four
definitely the latter half has been
quite a [ __ ] miss uh it's I I believe
it's because we're seeing the
results of what the pandemic had done to
production and so what we're seeing is
the the
final draws like okay so in 2008 right
there was a writer strike and so it's
the subsequent movies after that a
couple years after that were pretty kind
of trash yeah because the writers quit
yeah and so it's like
um uh Quantum Solace at 007 movie
apparently Daniel Craig had to write the
rest of the movies
actor had to write this [ __ ] because
there was no writers because they were
on strike
so a lot of movies if you go back and
look at like movies from 2008 2009
they're pretty lackluster because the
writers quit I'm not quit but we're on
strike and so what we're seeing now like
and why I try not to be so hard on these
films is because they had to live
through a pandemic and try to produce
this thing you know through this
pandemic you know and this is the result
of what we're gonna get they're just
picking up the pieces yeah at that point
yeah I mean also too and I'm pretty sure
we touched on this as well is that I
really really do believe that Marvel is
going to have to figure out what films
should stay as films and what things
should stay a series yeah right but
obviously it's a money grab because even
the films that we disliked made billions
of dollars and millions of top of
millions of dollars yeah it's just
certain things that you can't do in an
hour and a half it's just not possible I
mean the idea that you're gonna somehow
consolidate 400 episodes or 400 comic
books in a matter of an hour and a half
where you can explain all these detail
and new ones it's really really [ __ ]
hard to do and obviously you have to do
it in a series of films but
it's just it's difficult like I
definitely feel for them which I believe
why phase four at the beginning was so
good is because a huge part of it was
what series series right Loki a series
one division a series Falcon when a
soldier I like that a lot that one was
so [ __ ] good and once again that was
a series each episode was an hour long
and they could really really let [ __ ]
breathe let you really process
um like uh what the [ __ ] these people
are really going through
yeah
um but for Thor Ragnarok like I really
just wanted it to be like 15 minutes
longer you know yeah just let it breathe
a little the other part was um there was
kind of a jump where
I didn't see Gore butchering a whole lot
of gods
yeah yeah yeah yeah and what apparently
happened was there was a scene where
when Gore loses his face like so he has
all these tattoos right apparently there
was a scene where he just tears his skin
off
you know and he becomes this antagonist
like this the scary figure he does later
with this sharp dark like black teeth
and [ __ ] like there was a transitional
scene that they cut because they said it
was too dark that would have been good I
would have enjoyed to see it but
apparently there's like a lot of [ __ ] on
The Cutting Room floor that we didn't
get to see so hopefully I don't know
Disney plus give us the three-hour
version who knows I would love to see
that [ __ ] yeah that'll be really [ __ ]
amazing yeah yeah I mean
like I said I understand it is what it
is I understand like I don't have too
many bad things to say about it because
look I I enjoy Dumb and Dumber yeah not
the greatest film in the world but it's
a one of the greatest comedies in the
world but that's the other thing too
look at
how many of those comedies we grew up
with would they be able to come out in
theaters again
would a movie like Nacho Libre or even
Napoleon Dynamite be able to come out in
theaters or with movies like that go
straight to streaming like look at Adam
Sandler yeah yeah all this stuff has
just come straight out to streaming I
guess people don't go out to theaters to
just see these irreverent comedies
anymore yeah yeah yeah yeah so I I feel
like okay maybe this one Thor love and
thunder was like you know those Harold
and Kumar films you know the Dude
Where's My Car
you know but you know putting that stuff
back out in theaters putting a big IP on
it and people will go out and watch it
and like I think it's made six seven
hundred million now so it's a numbers
game people know and you know the
studios know too they're not really
thinking about
what's going to make this the best they
just know that no matter what we put out
people are still gonna [ __ ] watch
this [ __ ] they're definitely not trying
to win Oscars yeah that's that doesn't
matter to them yeah yeah I think that's
where the series come in like they they
can really understand those are going to
win some [ __ ] Emmys have you seen
Moon Knight hmm
here's how I assess it it's some of the
best [ __ ] acting I've ever seen in
the most boring Story Ever Told
uh what's this thing Oscar Isaac holy
[ __ ] he [ __ ] kills it he kills it
it's amazing like with the subject
matter but the story itself
you know but and then I I
I look at it then the phase four as a
whole and what's been happening it's
like holy [ __ ] it's quantity over
quality yeah that's what it's become now
and speaking of dude
did you see the new trailer for Black
Panther yeah that [ __ ] looks good
it looks [ __ ] good Brian googler dude
Creed one
oh my God one of my favorite films too
it's how you should do boxing movies he
really set a standard for boxing movies
and like Sylvester Stallone got a Best
Supporting Actor not for his role in
that too that's amazing he killed it in
that for being a supporting character it
was supposed to be a Rocky movie yeah he
he [ __ ] took it up and killed it but
that's also why I hate Creed too because
Sylvester Stallone took it over and
wrote the movie yeah yeah he owns
property so he was like Ryan coogler
it's it's so funny he's so [ __ ]
Oakland is hilarious to me yeah
literally said like look at her ball
head right over here I was cracking the
[ __ ] up because by the way too doesn't
matter how you speak it's all about your
[ __ ] art his art he's a [ __ ]
amazing filmmaker killer amazing and so
the second trailer I was watching and
I'm like dude I have super high hopes
for this one it looks [ __ ] amazing
and by I don't know who the New Black
Panther is but I'm pretty sure we know
who it is right I
if okay if we want to make like theories
and guesses
um we have iron heart coming in do you
know who ironheart is no who's ironheart
um so in the comics they had I think
they just introduced her in the past 10
years in the comics where she is the
next Iron Man
um she's a Genius Like New York uh Black
American girl who's just [ __ ] crazy
and builds her own suit
and she becomes the new Iron Man of you
know this current MCU series because
Tony Stark died Tony Stark died yeah and
so they're introducing her into this
which is going to be dope so I can I
think she and Sherry are like really
good friends I think you see them doing
the dab the wakanda dab and
um but the New Black Panther
I don't know I don't know if it'll work
but they might be bringing back Michael
B Jordan This podcast is brought to you
by Magic mine my friends if you haven't
heard of magic mind you are going to be
in for a treat um magicmine sent me a
box of their stuff and they wanted me to
try the product which is something that
I really enjoy that companies do is when
they send me something to try before I
even endorse it because I ain't doing it
unless I try it out so magic mine sent
me these little uh Magic mind matcha
shots and it was supposed to help me
with my productivity and I gotta tell
you [ __ ] amazing before I actually
shot this podcast uh I took a shot of
the magic mine specifically because we
were going to talk about Marvel things
and we were gonna unpack some very deep
topics and you know when you're running
around all day sometimes you just need a
little help with something and it's
beyond caffeine and that's where magic
mine steps in if you guys don't know I'm
actually really hyper caffeine sensitive
so magic mine has been like a good
medium to step away from too much coffee
and it's it's pretty freaking awesome
man it helps with like stress anxiety
and if I take too much coffee I can't
really sleep at night so taking magic
mine especially with like the cognitive
benefits of it and on this podcast has
been pretty [ __ ] amazing if you're
like me I totally recommend you go check
them out at magicmine.co brain and join
the community of go-getters you can also
use my discount code brain20 so you can
get 40 off your subscription or 20 off
your first one-time purchase my 40 code
only lasts 10 days so hurry up one sick
and that's magicmind.co slash brain and
use promo code
brain20 my friends if you want to get
that fatty fatty discount on an amazing
amazing product check it out click the
link and get to it magic mine baby
I don't know if that's going to work I I
have a feeling it's um you know the
leader of the bodyguards the female
bodyguards oh yeah okay yeah I think
it's her
if it's her I would be so [ __ ] happy
she's so badass I love her dude there is
a screenshot of you could see a black
panther like the suit in the arm right
yeah I must say it's a kind of a
feminine look that's what I'm saying
because it's one of the women I'm I
think it's a woman and it has to be her
if it's not her then somebody explain my
boner
my dick got a little hard and if it
fight as a dude I'm gonna be in a very
weird spot just a little Chub yeah I was
like oh why hello and um just from the
trail alone it looks like they gave a
lot
more for Angela Bassett yeah [ __ ]
really shine in her acting because of
course this movie is going to be about
pain because in the film itself uh
challah dies yeah too as I mean because
they they announced they're not going to
replace Chadwick Boseman yeah in the
store they're gonna honor absolutely
cannot replace him who would you replace
him with who
Michael Jai White
Wesley Snipes Wesley Snipes there's no
way yeah this isn't like the [ __ ] 90s
too where suddenly you just have [ __ ]
Aunt Viv be a different person
we're not doing that not doing that it's
not excusable anymore like people are
going to complain about that stuff so to
replace
t'challa with somebody else that's
worthy of the Black Panther suit I feel
like it's going to be her yeah yeah it
has to be
it it could be one or the other but I I
really hope that
like I I believe in Ryan coogler I'm
weary about phase four or where MCU is
heading but then man they give a lot of
reverence for Black Panther in their
films they give them their space to tell
the story that they need to and I trust
it yeah and I just hope that they don't
have shitty CGI let me ask you this and
I you know we were talking about this on
JK news and this is a very interesting
subject right because
a lot of people are especially in the
comic book World they are getting upset
at these changes that are happening
specifically because they feel like
they're pushing a woke narrative right
right
and there was a new person on the block
that's creating this new comic book
series he's I think he is a former
Marvel writer or something like that
right
um comic book writer but now they're
doing a mission to make superheroes
their own set of superheroes a whole new
universe has nothing to do with DC or
Marvel yeah but they're saying that
they're committed to not
let wokeness affect these characters
right and I think like the person who
started it all I think he's a young
black man he was talking about how
you know wokenicious day out of comic
books and you know a lot of these like
social justice issues shouldn't be in
this and to my mind I'm like actually I
don't know if that's the case because
that's what comic books were based off
of this is like the heart and soul of
comic books actually they were taught
they were tackling a lot of social
issues with this stuff so in my mind I'm
thinking like I understand what you're
saying right because when a lot of like
big companies have issues with not
trying to rock the boat so much so they
don't lose money right maybe that's what
you're talking about but in the general
scope of things then you don't really
know what these comic books are about
because they've always done that since
day one yeah like I remember this Nuna
unfriended me right
because she was walking by some
newsstand and then there was an X-Men
comic book where two gay mutants were
getting married and she posted a picture
of like oh my God I can't believe this
is happening and I commented like do you
know what the X-Men are about yeah
they're about civil rights you know
we've talked about this the last time
too like
you know it's I think peoples want to
label [ __ ] as wokeness right because I
don't know whether they don't want to be
educated they don't give a [ __ ] about
you know world's issues or they just
never saw the past comics for what it
was originally about yeah but I truly do
believe yeah you can have Comics that
are not about anything about our lives
like fantasy books you know Dragon Ball
Z isn't really about anything you know
like this whole story arc between X-Men
like the mutants and humans is about
xenophobia less are you [ __ ] out of
your mind that's just a heavy ass
[ __ ] subject growing up as a kid
watching that [ __ ] people protesting
outside of the White House talking about
we want these mutants dead we want them
out of here yeah why is one of the
biggest villains in X-Men a senator yeah
you know because he's making the laws
that are taking away rights for the
mutants and they just want their civil
rights putting them in cages yes which
is even a reflection of our time now
yeah I mean look at what days of future
past that movie was about they touched
on the beginning mutants getting rounded
up and [ __ ] exterminated touching a
little bit on you know the Holocaust
yeah too I mean and
um that's why even in the first X-Men um
opening scene one of the greatest
opening scenes in all comic books where
young Magneto is in [ __ ] Auschwitz
you know oh that's right right what do
you think this [ __ ] is about you know
like it's touching on all civil rights
all human rights for equality this is
what it's about but if you want to make
a you know story that's not about
equality or civil rights then you're
gonna have more or less something like a
Zack Snyder point of view of how we see
superheroes that these are gods and they
don't give a [ __ ] about you why should
Superman give a [ __ ] about us right
that's what
Invincible touches on right and you're
gonna tell me oh invincible's not woke
sure it's it's not but it's touching on
some something very important in the
philosophy of how we see things yeah but
if you just want to make a comic book
about punching and kicking then [ __ ] I'm
telling you there's Dragon Ball it's
great too yeah yeah you know it's fine
that's the interesting thing and you
know just to touch on this like topic
too do you ever have issues of for
example people
you know it's like the whole Little
Mermaid thing right
or in Little Little Mermaid they they
were casting a young black girl for it
and then people flipped the [ __ ] out
right
and I don't really think on this like
why does that bother people
right and I think what I came to a
conclusion and I talked and you know on
JK news I joke about a lot of things I
don't really expound on thoughts and
this is what this podcast is for
um
I'm thinking the reason why people
dislike it is because it [ __ ] with
their childhood
yes I guess I think that's just really
the basis of it yeah I am used to seeing
this redhead white girl and this is what
I grew up on why do you have to change
it because like 80 percent of America
being white
you know and like half of that being the
women or whatever can see that like so
that's what I'm wondering too then are
white women complaining or is it white
men complaining right yeah yeah just to
make some [ __ ] noise yeah right and
the other thing I have to say too
there's no [ __ ] mermaids in real life
who gives a [ __ ] so Africa doesn't have
fish yeah you know what the [ __ ] kidding
me I I actually because I thought of
this little mermaid example I went
online and I found some old tweets from
people and somebody else brought this up
they're like well you know mermaids is
like a Nordic like Norse Legend thing
right and they are white and so it's not
even historically accurate but like hey
mermaids don't exist how about that
[ __ ] my my friend he actually explained
it to me too like when I say what do you
say when you know WWE like wrestling's
not real and he says Superman's not real
yeah Batman's not real you know but the
idea is like what is the story about
right and this is the what reason why I
love like the first six Fast and Furious
after seven I hate it but the idea is
like tell me we still watch it though
yeah
we always want to watch it but is really
about the cars like is wrestling really
about what happens in the ring right or
is there so much drama happening and
story happening outside of the Ring and
then they solve their problems in the
ring they head on their issues with
their beef and it all comes down to what
happens there and who wins and comes out
on top whatever verbally or personally
that they're going through right yeah
yeah Fast and Furious they got their own
issues and you know how they solve it
with a race yeah okay they solve it with
their car family yeah that's that's what
it's about it's not like about like all
the like cars and race like about all
that [ __ ] and stunts but then you have
to be invested in the characters like
and what they're going through and what
it means for them to have to use their
cards to solve their problems yeah yeah
yeah like the wrestlers have to use
their Rock bottoms and people elbows to
solve their problems you know and also
too like
there was a huge uproar about Disney
because of the Buzz Lightyear right did
you see it I didn't see it I heard it
was bad it was bad so I didn't care to
see it so who cares about the gay
kissing thing if it's a bad movie I
don't give a [ __ ] I I barely remembered
about the gay kissing that's the least
it was a film's problem I heard it was
like in the background or something yeah
and then there was two gay guys kissing
and then you know I read a lot of tweets
about this stuff you know because
Twitter is always right but that's just
kind of where people complain the most
like Twitter that's what Twitter's about
so people were just kind of like I don't
like it when Disney shoves gay [ __ ] in
my face and I was expecting this scene
where Buzz Lightyear whips out his dick
and he's just basting a girl a dude with
it or something yeah you know but it was
like two dudes like just pecking in the
back or some [ __ ] two women oh it was
two women yeah two older women pretty
much like
is the same thing with like stock
strange to America's parents lesbian
love that [ __ ] yeah
like you love watching in on PornHub but
for some reason you don't like to see it
on the internet there's two guys I
understand but two women what the [ __ ]
man no I'm kidding I mean and I have to
look at who's making the most think like
conservatives sure oh yeah for sure
yeah I didn't know what it was about but
then I like I said I read there like it
was just in the background I'm like okay
cool that that was the least of the
film's problems yeah right and like and
then it goes into this other subject too
where I was reading it where people were
complaining about oh why do they have to
go ahead and start making these
characters gay out of nowhere like it's
like Superman's son is gay and there was
all these other like examples that they
were bringing out yeah and so I started
thinking to myself okay what is the
problem here
I think obviously beyond the the the
direct answer of people being very
conservative and they have their
Christian ideals and beliefs and this is
what's [ __ ] them up in the head I
think a lot of it really does have to do
with Nostalgia and I can kind of
empathize in the sense of yeah I I think
like if I had this character like to say
I don't know Superman he's marrying Lois
Lane he's absolutely in love with her
right and she's his moral compass
throughout the whole comic book series
she grounds him and then the next thing
you know he's like dude I [ __ ] like
dick I don't know I'd be a little thrown
off too because I would think about the
why like is this just because you want
this to be a part of this universe
because of wokeness and that's where I
understand what they're talking about
yeah
so in my mind I guess like the medium
for something like that I'm not saying
that that is something that happens it's
like oh if you want to bring in new
social characters that kind of talks
about the current situation that we have
in this country do it with a new
character yeah give give these old
people their [ __ ] Nostalgia and then
do these subjects with a new character
yeah that might be the the best medium
for it yeah I think that's fine and you
know but what we have been seeing is
like new characters you know that are
gay or what is still a problem
classified yeah and it's still a problem
yeah like so far what I'm seeing I'm not
seeing like other characters like if you
have a problem with Korg being gay it's
like but you didn't like
you didn't know what what he was before
whether he was hetero or not you just
figured it out now and what the [ __ ] do
you care about two rocks [ __ ] each
other yeah you know who cares who cares
yeah that's you know it was one of the
things like I really got to look at too
is like
you know why they have to complain it
just sounds like a lot of hate but these
people exist in the world Mermaids Don't
yeah you know uh like so many things
don't actually exist but for some reason
if you want to throw them into your
fantasy it [ __ ] up with what you had in
your imagination going back to whether a
book is better than a movie when someone
says the book was better I'm like so
you're telling me that you have a better
imagination than Steven Spielberg yeah
you have a better imagination than all
these [ __ ] billion dollar directors
it was hilarious I uh you know to go
back on the topic of that witness thing
we have a mutual friend too and
sometimes I I read his tweets because
he's been on this extra awoke Asian tip
thing constantly tweeting and putting it
on Facebook all it literally has never
talked about any of this stuff ever as
long as we've known him okay and then
you know it's getting to the point where
it's like so ridic this is the type of
wokeness I think that these comic book
writers who want to start their own
universe is talking about yeah where you
know you know I love this guy but he
tweeted something ridiculous he goes I
don't know how I feel about you know
representation in Asian media for a lot
of casting this is like one of those
gray areas for me should Asian people be
casted in like medieval movies I'm like
no they shouldn't because we weren't
there
you [ __ ] idiot
love to be in Game of Thrones well not
Game of Thrones that's not even real I
would love to be in like some kind of
[ __ ] Celtic movie right yeah
I love that [ __ ] how weird would I look
there I don't belong there it's not even
anywhere near accurate and they're kind
of basing off of real life [ __ ] yeah
yeah what are you talking about right
now dude that's like me I mean this is
kind of in a bit of a hyperbole but
that's like um
uh what's it called uh Tarantino yeah
right he does the film about uh with
Django right and then you see a lineup
of all these slaves and then I'm one of
them
what for representation purposes yeah
yeah that's stupid shut up
shut up now you're just talking just to
[ __ ] talk yeah now you're just
complaining just to [ __ ] complain
yeah like there are actual reasons and
like battles that we can fight that
doesn't make sense for you to even put
that out in The Ether to say hey okay I
don't know if I'm being ridiculous or
not uh but I think maybe I feel a
certain way maybe we should be in these
films no we shouldn't shut the [ __ ] up
it would be weird it wouldn't even make
sense it would it would distract from
the film or the TV show so much it's
like we we do have our own stories man
if you just maybe read a little bit of
your own history bro that's some dope
[ __ ] yeah I'd love to see a [ __ ]
Korean War film yeah or maybe play a
Call of Duty that's in the Korean War
but no we don't have those dude how
[ __ ] wild would that be yeah but like
hey maybe we should advocate for those
right but then yeah we don't have those
that's something you can [ __ ]
complain about yeah but don't try to act
like oh why aren't we in the new Lord of
the Rings
give a [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] if I'm
in that movie or not dude
[ __ ] guy in there or whatever that's
what you're talking about we have our
real stories too that can be represented
too but I I really think
the argument itself like it's almost
futile like that's look at what this guy
is you're telling me like he's making an
anti-wolf comic book
I'm good for him honestly because he has
his convictions and he's [ __ ] doing
something about it he's creating
something you know but if you're an
Asian American or whatever and you're
like want to be included into something
else and you're not you know what [ __ ]
it then make your own thing yeah let's
make our own thing that's the point of
creativity and and creation you know
creation is built like solely in us as
as human beings because we're lonely
yeah because we don't we didn't have
[ __ ] 200 000 years ago so you know I do
we could carve something we can get some
charcoal and start drawing on the cave
walls be created for a [ __ ] reason
you know we expressed for a reason
there's I can't imagine a caveman 200
000 years ago like hey why didn't you
draw my people on your wall yeah what
the [ __ ] get the [ __ ] right draw your
own [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah that's what I'm
saying like the complaining has
complaints have its merits like where
it's coming from but who you're giving
it to I believe like has its limits that
was my biggest issue that I had with
this the original Asian American
movement with the film stuff they go you
should cast me in okay hold on a second
why do you want this person who you are
so much demonizing as this person who
doesn't understand the Nuance of the
Asian American Experience to write a
film about your Asian American
Experience that's [ __ ] nonsense yeah
go do your own thing make it yourself
because nobody else is going to be able
to duplicate or replicate all those
[ __ ] things that you went through as
a kid not possible and you're waiting
for that role and that director isn't
even gonna know where you're coming from
because he doesn't [ __ ] know us or
get us right I saw this clip it was
pretty amazing where um someone was
questioning Denzel Washington about like
why did the director of this film have
to be black right and the whole cast in
the panel are like rolling their eyes
right and Denzel had something really
important to say he was like Steven
Spielberg made Schindler's List you know
excellent [ __ ] film Martin Scorsese
made Goodfellas excellent [ __ ] film
Steven Spielberg could have made
Goodfellas but he doesn't know the
culture it wouldn't have been what it is
without Martin scorsi Cersei making it
Mars Scorsese in his own right could
have made Schindler's List but he
doesn't know that culture and it
wouldn't have been what it is that's
what we're seeing that's good it's the
culture that matters
so when you're complaining to a white
producer to a white director and [ __ ]
you're not gonna hear back from them
yeah because they don't know what the
[ __ ] to do I think people have to
realize that when you keep yelling and
jogging at white people like do better
yeah they're [ __ ] stuck like do
better with what with what they don't
know what the [ __ ] to do yeah you know
that's why it's important for us to
create our own [ __ ] yeah you know that's
the smart thing and like I know it's oh
Dave it's so much easier said than done
a hundred [ __ ] percent it is hard
yeah but guess what you have to have the
[ __ ] guts to do it yeah you're going
to have to and there has to be a
community that's going to back you up
and there are those things right like
that's that's the thing too like how can
I explain to somebody what it's like to
have a mom
call you fat and ask you why you're not
eating
and then you know everything everywhere
all at once yeah like
touched it the way it could because the
director knew the culture yeah like how
can I explain to you what it's like to
to go to your grandma's house and smell
this this burning incense that you would
smell every time that the smell of a
Korean church that every [ __ ]
creature smells like whether it's I'm in
Seattle whether I'm in Dallas Texas in
New York Jersey whatever they all smell
the exact same how can you explain these
experiences it's almost
it's it's hard to do you cannot do it
but you can show it in film and the only
way you can do it is when you've
experienced it yourself it's people know
these things you have this in your own
personal lives where you literally say
in stories I would tell you the story
but you had to be there yeah same
[ __ ] thing I could tell this somebody
to do this film for me but they weren't
there they didn't live this [ __ ] they
didn't know what it [ __ ] felt like
and that's coattailing when you complain
that way though right like hey if you
put me into a little mermaid or what
anything whatever into this space then
we can tell our perspective of it but
it's like it sounds like you have
something to say why don't you just make
your own [ __ ] instead of giving it to
some other IP right listen the only
[ __ ] thing that I heard about Little
Mermaid that made me die laughing and I
was gonna put and I literally wrote this
as a joke
got in here and I haven't made the joke
myself
how's I'm just gonna say it
the only thing that made me like die
laughing was like I was literally
writing this joke I was like the reason
the only reason why [ __ ] Little
Mermaid being a black woman doesn't make
any sense because she has to go in the
water
bro
that's it hey I grew up in a Black
Beauty Supply Store I know big facts
there's no there's not a single black
woman on her that has beautiful hair
that's gonna be like I'm jumping into
this water I was like that's the only
reason that's the only argument you
could [ __ ] make other than that I
don't want to hear it that's true man
like people like have these different
ideas of things but like I I see it too
like we talked about it before was the
corporate inclusion the forced uh
inclusion kind of thing too
um it does lose its merits in that point
too yeah um but then if the story
doesn't make a [ __ ] difference
whether they're white black Asian or
Latino like
I I really don't like see why it matters
either like people have a big problem
with black people being in the new
Amazon Prime Lord of the Rings
but it's like like why right it's all a
fantasy like it's all fantasy yeah it's
all fantasy people legit have a problem
with that yeah it's lord of the [ __ ]
Rings see that's the thing where I'm
like Asian people can be in that [ __ ]
because it's fantasy yeah the [ __ ] cares
so for me too like you watch the
original first six Star Wars how many
Asian people are in there the none oh so
Asian people don't go to space
oh no we're only the engineers who allow
you guys to get in a rocket ship and go
out there yeah we'll stay down here on
Earth you know all this like Maple Leaf
stuff race should have absolutely no
issue you know why because their cast
member is an alien with six tits on
their face all right
so if you're okay with that I'm pretty
sure we could have a couple of Ching
chongs in space we're fine we will be
okay yeah
I mean people like are I feel like
jumping on that train of just a
representation
[Music]
um without having any creativity yeah
they're skipping the line
you know that's what it is not not
saying oh you should [ __ ] work and
grind and all that said yes you should
but also like if you've got something
good and you got a good idea then make
it yourself dude don't be like I have a
oh I know how I would fit into Lord of
the Rings how about make your own
fantasy then yeah how about make your
own East Asian Southeast Asian fantasy
that's why like um
even though I didn't like Raya I was
just gonna say yeah I appreciated it
it's still its own Southeast Asian
fantasy story 100 100 and like that's
something I can get behind you know
that's something I appreciate and y'all
I don't want to say it out loud too but
I got ideas for like a korean-american
Disney film you know something that
speaks to us but I don't want a Korean
person to be the new Prince Charming in
some [ __ ] thing you know no I think
we have our own story to tell behind our
own culture and I think like look at
Moana
beautiful representation of like
Polynesian like Moana is one of my
favorites [ __ ] crying like ball my
eyes out like every time there the
grandma came on the screen bro the
grandma when she became the manta ray
that [ __ ] [ __ ] ball that [ __ ] wrecked
me dude hot tears in the theater yeah
yeah so like yes we
we do want to see ourselves I get it
right but then at the same time like
what you want to see and what you want
to create are two different things yeah
like could you imagine how would that
director uh let's say somebody who
wasn't Chinese American right have
directed that short bow
how could they have done it yeah how
dude watching that [ __ ] [ __ ] got me
yeah right it reminded me of my mom if
wrecked me dude I was like oh [ __ ] like
they they love you so much that they
just want you to be by but they won't
let you be your individual self yeah
like that is such I mean I'm pretty sure
it happens in a lot of other cultures
but Asian Americans do that a lot yeah
especially a mother to their son like
they forever you are this child to me
you know and they she just would not
live to the point where she would rather
just
snuff him out and keep her to herself in
selfishness right then rather let this
child live their own life yeah I mean
like uh uh turning red although it's
very cringe to me I mean but that's
because I was never a middle school girl
yeah yeah yeah but
um outside of it being a you know
Chinese Canadian story or whatever like
it still had a relatable story a
humanist Story down to its bones
you know but externally it had so much
of its culture that it could that could
be represented yeah and where it hold it
well enough where you could understand
the pressures that she's going through
you know and so did it matter that they
were Chinese you know at all yes and no
it was important for its for its
representation and it did it goddamn
[ __ ] well I had so many
that's so many I'd say two people I'm
exaggerating right now I cut that [ __ ]
out but um
two two people that's off the top of my
head I'm pretty sure I read more
but she went on a tirade and a rant
about how young kids how their her
three-year-old son shouldn't be watching
turning red right
and I just wrote back to her I was like
I didn't I had no idea that it was uh a
stranger's responsibility uh on when
they whether they decide what their kids
watch I thought that was your job yeah
what the [ __ ] are you taught what are
you talking about they're like well she
was like well since you don't seem to go
to church anymore you know them teaching
oh and bro I I literally paused for a
second I'm like I could wreck this
[ __ ] girl's life and I just looked at
her and I was like listen number one
I remember you at church you went to
church very casually in fact were you
were you spouting this [ __ ] when you
were sucking blah blah blah stick in the
back of the parking lot of church
yikes right I was like I don't have
amnesia [ __ ] yeah so don't talk to me
about what's holy and Pious when you
literally [ __ ] was was you were [ __ ]
guzzling dicks at the back of a
church-bark parking lot don't talk to me
about this [ __ ] or do you want me to put
that on your Facebook group I mean
people people want to be out loud
because they want to express some kind
of self-righteousness that's what I'm
saying and I was like okay listen I was
like I understand and I was writing this
and I was like and she was you know
after that she wrote that she just kind
of didn't say anything I was like you
don't have anything to say right now
right I was like it's very easy for you
to go ahead and get on your religious
religious pedestal and start you know
punching down and pointing down at
people but that's not even what this is
about I was like you didn't like the
fact that they talked about periods and
all this other [ __ ] demonstration like
strange eggs like it yeah the the the
red panda itself like wasn't just about
periods yeah it was so much that young
women go through throughout this entire
Earth yeah and for some reason you
showed a three-year-old that I don't
know tell you did he even understand it
why do you care yeah and then on top of
that she was kind of relegating into it
like this is what my Disney movies used
to be like when I was younger and I'm
like yes they [ __ ] work what are you
talking about [ __ ] what are you talking
about like oh the way that they uh this
kid is defying their parents oh for
reals Little Mermaid yeah I don't know
Jasmine from [ __ ] Aladdin [ __ ] what
are you talking about the selective
memory is what kills me the most the
thing that bothered her the most was the
fact that the child was being defiant
against her parents and going against
their wishes and rebelling and running
away
every [ __ ] Disney film is it what are
you talking about and she used Little
Mermaid as an example I was like did you
watch this
like do you do we want to see a Disney
film where the main character or the
parents getting their [ __ ] way yeah
and like lording over their kids and
then winning them over by their
obedience yeah what the [ __ ] kind of
movie is that who wants to see that [ __ ]
that's what I'm saying I like stuff that
she was complaining about is literally
the exact same Trope in her favorite
Disney films that she used as an example
that's how dumb you are you don't even
know what the [ __ ] you were watching
which goes to show just show your kid
turning red because they probably won't
know what the [ __ ] they're watching
either it's it's it's a ridiculous arm
good man from the jump because it's like
hey I don't know how to make movies so
you gotta make them the way I wanted to
like the [ __ ] is that yeah like if you
don't know and you're upset like bro
[ __ ] learn I don't know what to tell
you yeah like if you can't do it then
turn it off don't [ __ ] watch it
that's all I could say like there's so
many things we don't enjoy we sit
through it but we analyze it because of
the film nature yeah you know like my
Disney films were never like this yeah
the [ __ ] girl in the ocean that just
went up on land to go get some fresh
dick
[Music]
yeah really good idea run away from home
change myself so I could fit in yeah
yeah and then the original Little
Mermaid itself the original story is
like [ __ ] horrific apparently dude
it's crazy dude all these stories are
horrific yeah and then they gotta Disney
fight to make it acceptable and make it
cute and make it loving all that [ __ ]
look at what they did to Mulan you know
like yeah it it
[ __ ] gets Disney fight but you know what
if like I keep saying if you've got a
problem man get a piece of paper and a
pen write a better movie yeah just do it
just start you know and who knows put it
out there maybe someone pick it up I
don't know
the film is like teaching her young
daughter how to be rebellious even
though Aladdin is her favorite [ __ ]
movie blows my mind literally she runs
away from her dad goes into a bizarre
starts pretending like she's poor and
[ __ ] and then she gets her hand chopped
off yeah it starts falling in love with
the bad boy
what are you talking about be quiet
man you just have to like let [ __ ] be
like yeah it almost just doesn't matter
then you know what then just read the
Bible to your kid for the rest of his
life and tell me when he doesn't resent
you yeah you know yeah tell them about
the story where they were [ __ ] each
other in the ass and they started
turning into salt that's a great bedtime
story yeah it's all about Simon Gomorrah
tell them about David and Nathan man
those two were gay yeah
man like Nathan was supposed to be King
David's like Prophet but damn did they
love each other yeah you know what I'm
saying like like get the [ __ ] out of
here yeah tell them those [ __ ]
stories Dude tell them that story about
this girl who wasn't supposed to eat an
apple and this [ __ ] just the finest
[ __ ] eats this apple and [ __ ] the whole
world up yeah like
like look these
I I I I
kind of get that
uh side like because of whatever
overprotectiveness you know with their
kids you know you're gonna say some [ __ ]
then whatever it's it's [ __ ] dumb but
fine like you have your right to say it
but you they should know like it's kind
of [ __ ] stupid yeah well make your
points correct like at least have a
sound Point like don't use the examples
of the stuff that is exactly like the
film that you're criticizing you make
don't make any sense but it only goes to
prove the point that even you didn't
know what you were watching as a kid and
you didn't even see it yeah you didn't
see it at all someone says that's not my
Little Mermaid then fine read the
original story yeah the original story
is [ __ ] horrible the read the
original story of Little Red Riding Hood
yeah all these Germanic like like fairy
tales they're terrible they're made to
scare children into obedience yes and
then Disney made it more acceptable and
you know like loving and whatever bro
[ __ ] Sleeping Beauty is nuts terrible
King comes in rapes this girl in her
sleep and she's pregnant yeah all that
[ __ ] like you [ __ ] kidding me you
know I didn't even know about I was
driving to Sacramento in my car and I
just put they're like the real story of
Disney and I was like oh what is this I
started hearing it I was mortified yeah
oh they're [ __ ] raping this girl in
her sleep because the king couldn't have
was was having an affair with his wife
and then
with with the Sleeping Beauty and so he
would you know basically [ __ ] her while
she was in a coma and she woke up
pregnant
yeah what what kind of [ __ ] fairy
tale story is this what was going
through Walt Disney's mind to be like
you know what we should make this one
rated G he saw that he was like it's
kind of hot
freak the hell is that [ __ ] about I mean
going back to like representation
wokeness and all that [ __ ] too right
um you know uh Bob Kane he was known as
the creator of Batman and he got all the
[ __ ] credit for it right up until
Batman v Superman all of a sudden they
added a second name Batman and creators
created by Bob Kane and this guy named
Bill Finger Bill Finger was the actual
guy who drew Batman designed Batman oh
you know gave him his story where he
comes from what he does and Robin you
know he actually designed all that [ __ ]
for Bob Kane he is a [ __ ] idiot
apparently you know oh and Bill finger
is the one that created the Batman we
know what a tragic Name by the way yeah
but that was another thing Bill Finger
was a gay man
so when he introduced Robin it was like
a lover boy kind of situation if you
look at those old Comics it looked crazy
gay yeah because Bill Finger the Creator
who was drawing all of it was gay yeah
you know and that's why if you see
Batman and Robin the one with George
Clooney
his relationship with Chris O'Donnell
pretty gay yeah it's pretty that's so
funny this like gay comic provided
basically subliminal to everybody yeah
so who the [ __ ] going back there and
like who's gonna have a problem with
like a new movie where Batman's gay go
back to the original Source bro that's
gay
Batman's gay
so I don't know what you want to [ __ ]
say like it like whether it matters to
you or not it's like it's not my Batman
well the guy who created it says it's
his Batman yeah you know look it's all
make believe you know what the Quick Fix
is he's not gay in your head yeah
just ignore it move on just like you
always do you [ __ ] bigot yeah
do that one page where [ __ ] Robin is
[ __ ] jacking him off behind the back
just just move past that page never
happens and then go straight to the
action part yeah you'll be perfectly
fine that's what I do when I watch porn
when that guy's about to come I cover it
yeah
why you gotta cut to him man why do you
have to do the under ball angle dude I
don't need to see this
terrible but sometimes I want to talk to
these porn directors what are you doing
and he goes you know what I'm gay I'm
gay oh okay
exactly what are you gonna say he's gay
you're watching you're watching some
[ __ ] from a gay man and if he makes gay
characters but makes it ambiguous like
what's it to you you're too stupid to
figure it out in the past that's what it
is yeah and like the idea too is you
know
everything is so gay now it's like I
don't think everything is I think it's
sprinkled here and about because it's a
representation of life that's how it's
always been exist they [ __ ] exist and
it happens all around us it's just there
yeah like one of the I think I used an
example before
I really enjoyed
um this I forgot what series it was but
Abraham Lim you know we was kicking with
him he is gay and he's playing a gay
reporter yeah right but they didn't do a
whole story arc about why he's gay or
whatever he's just a gay reporter just
he kisses his boyfriend they have a
relationship and it's just a part of
life it normalizes it so I mean it's
important if you're telling a
coming-of-age story where a man has to
come out of the closet that makes sense
right that's not shoving it down her
throat that's a Coming of Age like a
real story to get to understand somebody
you know but then yeah I remember what
was this show um how to get away with
murder
yeah that that was it was a very
intriguing show very until until it was
just like yo everyone's just [ __ ]
each other oh yeah until Viola Davis was
gay okay all of a sudden and then she
was bisexual and then she doesn't know
what she is anymore I'm like this was so
unnecessary it was for the sake of your
jaw-dropping shock factor and I think
this is maybe what once again going back
to that Wellness thing is probably the
stuff that I dislike that maybe that
they're talking about it's the it's
closer to like showing and not telling
yeah if you can act it out and show a
life you know in a lifestyle or whatever
like someone who they are then you can
understand like what they're doing like
you can ex like you process it but it's
not like like everything that defines
them right yes like if if a there's a
story like out there that's just so much
about I'm Asian and I'm so Asian and I'm
Asian yo
it's like that it where's the [ __ ]
story where's the rest of the story yeah
you know but yeah the there's the
identity thing and then there's
literally like okay as a human you know
like what like are you going through and
what part of it because you're gay like
there are these obstacles because that
Society throws at you that's so much
more interesting dude look at [ __ ] uh
Moonlight yeah yeah I actually haven't
seen that one yet oh you haven't seen
Moonlight yeah visually [ __ ] stunning
dude I gotta pick that up it's it's very
slow paced really [ __ ] good I watched
that [ __ ] like two or three times I was
like really good and I love that story
dude it makes sense everything is
perfect for it and it's done with so
much Nuance it's like watching this guy
you know find his sexuality growing up
as a kid as a young black man in his
name like it's [ __ ] nuts right and
that's The Coming of Age part yeah
that's so much better as a storytelling
device instead of the character identity
and making it the whole movie that's
what a lot of people [ __ ] up when they
start writing you know and there are
certain like peers in this space that I
see they write like they still write
like that till this day and it
aggravates me so [ __ ] much because
I'm like you are so beyond this right
now that you don't have to do this and
when you when you kind of there's like
people who create the joke first before
the script and they try to base the
whole script around the joke and it's
just trash the whole the whole thing is
trash and you can really see into the
writer's mind when what they're real
what they're trying to do then is do
something like make straight people
uncomfortable or make straight people
have to you know eat it up without
really like expounding on a a truer
story on oneself on somebody I think
that's way more important and at that
point if they are gay or not like
like is so much more interesting
you know like and if it they are gay and
that is an important part like like I
said it doesn't just have to be their
identity and that's the story yeah but
then like their Journey along that way
like we were just saying before like I
lost 100 pounds
that's the end of the story no my life
continues yeah and I'm and even for me
myself my identity isn't found in how
much weight I lost or what I've
accomplished or all these things my
journey continues which is why it is I
still have a million stories about
whether I'm fat or skinny or whatever
yeah I'm me yeah you know and there's so
much more that
you know explains or like can can
express who I am just by the stories I
tell and has nothing to do with me being
Asian yeah and and you know just to you
know add to all that in terms of like
filmmaking too this is in general what I
like to look for when I enjoy films the
most it's how people expound on these
ideas usually like the general topic of
what the movie is about is like the it's
more of the backdrop than what the whole
thing is right so for example with you
know with the film group that I did
Google wasn't about the riots right [ __ ]
was about these brothers and this other
family and them trying to get along and
understand each other
they're more similar they are dissimilar
but they don't see it because they're
going through their personal struggles
the backdrop is the riots right and it
it had um more microscopic view about
these two different families that
represented the bigger idea of where the
rights were coming from but it made it
much more personal between these two and
that was way more important than like
making a documentary
because we all know what the rights are
we don't need to see that what we're
trying to do is kind of dig deeper and
then see something else that was a big
issue was like these two communities yes
what were they going through what were
they thinking about oh they're a lot
more similar than we thought yes right
and sometimes when you when you are hurt
and you feel pain you don't care about
what somebody else is going through you
can only see what you what you're going
through and that's what to me what made
that film so [ __ ] great to me you
know and that's what I want to see in
the Bible until they shared the same
pain yep right at the climax level no
spoilers guys gotta go watch it yeah but
when they shared that same pain you know
like and I I went to one of the screens
when he came to Seattle and then it was
a q a and Justin explained it too like
his character and um the other character
I forget Curtis Curtis yeah that they
essentially are two sides of the same
coin although Justin's character is the
main character of the film that's who
we're following but you know they're
they're anger their hurt their pain and
then their struggle and their grind it's
the same yeah you know but then
they don't see it right up until yeah
they feel the same pain together yeah
and that's so much more important when
you break it down and you and you can
humanize people and understand that we
are humans not taking away the fact that
we are a certain race it's not like in
the movies all of a sudden people lost
their color yeah it's not that you know
but then when a story can break it down
and you start seeing two you know homo
sapiens
you know interacting and having these
Human Experience then it doesn't matter
if they're trans black latino Jewish
Asian white gay like where that story is
there for the sake of them being human
beings that's what's important yeah
well guys
we were actually supposed to do a review
something else too this is actually
really great
um
you guys can catch Ed at Ed parkvp
genius brain every Sunday at 12 p.m uh
genius brain uh secret society Club has
either dropped or will be dropping make
sure that you get those pre-orders
[ __ ] amazing same same amazing
quality their secret society puts out
but I'm doing it I don't I don't want to
create merch I want to create some
meaningful [ __ ] so once again inspired
by my trip to Korea check it out
um every Sundays at 12 p.m and we'll
catch you guys next time